okay well welcome everyone to our weekly
demise research conference although this
week we're actually having two
conferences so this one is today on
Tuesday and then also will have our
regularly scheduled one on Thursday our
speaker today is Janice Patterson who is
in the bioinformatics and computational
biology track and is going to be
defending her master's thesis proposal
so for those who aren't familiar with
this process she will give a
presentation to all of us and then
there'll be some time for questions the
public will then be dismissed leaving
behind her committee who will ask her
additional questions and then she will
be dismissed and the committee will
determine whether she's ready to go on
and do her master's thesis work Janice
comes to ohsu by way of PSU where she
has a bachelor's degree in biochemistry
and she's currently working in the lab
of dr. Michael Heinrich who's in the
division of hematology oncology and also
at the Portland VA research center so
so my proposal today is called
understanding what's under the hood
increasing accessibility at no mixed
results so I'll begin by starting to
talk about my motivation and background
as well as my aims and in it which will
include two use cases and some
preliminary metrics and the impact of my
impact the next steps of my project so
my project really stems from this
problem of big data this figure
emphasizes a comp but the growth the
problems with combining patient data
from clinical information to patient
background history and really how
diverse and complicated the information
that is and how you need increasing ways
of processing and transforming like
increasingly complicated ways of
processing and transforming the data to
make it make meaning and a meaning out
of it and make sense out of it and and
really it's about and ultimately when
you get your results from annex or about
blind trust and really you don't we
don't you don't understand like you
don't really know what what like if the
weather the transformation of the data
kept the fidelity of the data and this
figure doesn't even include the omics of
a part of it so the science so a lot of
the genomics and like proteomics part of
patient patient information so this
quote by two key and wilke I think kind
of prophetically like emphasizes one of
the problems of big data and he
emphasizes the importance of exposure of
your data and how difficult it is to
expose data for human analysis and in
this problem exposure is really a big
problem with the like large datasets
because you have these you have these
you have these files that are Allah that
you can't even open with like a word
processor or any text processor so it's
really hard to get yourself to get your
hands around the data and really expose
that data so one of the main
one of the large problems that has come
with this problem of big data is this
problem with a reproducibility and this
figure shows that is a bigger study and
it shows and they attempted to reproduce
67 in-house published the data and so
and they found that only twenty-five
percent were reproducible and while
sixty-five percent have inconsistencies
between the publish finding and
reproduce finding so this problem of
reproducibility increases with increase
with so increases with the increasing
amount of data that you have so it's
easier to make it something like
mistaken assumptions about the data when
you can't expose it as well as multiple
transformations that have to happen to
the data to make anything anything
meaningful interpretable from your data
so how do we get underneath all this
data or underneath the hood so to speak
so in one way is to change how we
interact with it and how we and how we
really think about it that's figure
representing the Gulf of valuation and
execution kind of represents this gulf
these gaps that we have between what we
what we conceptually think as well as
this world of data and the gulf of
evaluation and represents sort of what
the gap of interpretation the the effort
that we have to do that we have to put
in to interpret the data and whether
that data ezra met our expectations and
the gulf of execute and the gulf of
execution kind of represents a gap of
usability and between what we want and
what what the data and the world can
tell us and what we can do with it and
you can see that even for my toy example
but there were there there are two
transformations that have to happen to
the data to get something meaningful
interpret all that answered our question
so and what so increasing the
interaction of data can really narrow
this gap and you not only do you get
narrow the gap so you can directly see
the impact of these transformations and
and and you mediately get beat feedback
of these transformation and exposing the
data immediately it was the interactive
data which like visualizations and
things like that and it makes data more
accessible interpretable ultimately so
interactive data has extensions beyond
static data and this table classifies
the components of interactive data and I
get it obviously you have the being able
to view and visualize the data so that's
important that's one of the components
and then you also interactive data has
also the ability to manipulate your data
you can filter it you can you can you
can filter it verify assumptions as well
as like diagnose diagnose your data as
well and this process is this process
and provenance also it lets us live to
the way it's a way so interactive data
visualization lets us view the
processing of the data directly so you
can kind of see the story of what
happened of the processing that occurred
to the data by looking at the
visualization as well so you can do as
well as share as well as sharing your
visualization with others and they can
pop and see the processes that you
implement in the transformations that
you can pipette minute on data
so so may aim one will be to develop
these metrics and visualizations and
statistical summary is for to assess the
robustus of computational methods and
algorithms in high-throughput sequencing
and I will be focusing on like
downstream analysis computational
methods and algorithms and my second
name is to implement these in two use
cases copy number variation and
chromatin immunoprecipitation so my
first game is to develop these metrics
to assess the algorithm algorithm and
computational reproducibly and these are
really general metrics so they like
their for high-throughput sequencing so
that assess reproducibility repinlike
and basically the validity of the of
your method and I'll do this in an
interactive context and like so
basically thinking of ways to basically
use interactive visualization to
implement these as well as integrate
them together with other metrics so what
is high-throughput sequencing or
massively parallel sequencing I meet
this figure just too just so you can get
a feeling of what the results look like
and um so you take DNA and in this
example you take DNA and you fragment it
and you put in there is a massively
parallel sequencing and would you get
from it are millions of 50 to 100 base
pairs base pair reads and these are
aligned to the reference genome usually
by species and you can see how fidelity
and like I will crucial this step is
really to the do any downstream
processing like any like thing anything
you're going to be trying to find
afterwards this is a crucial step and
you'll get metrics like read depths and
read coverage and the above example i
have read us kind of shows an example of
read deaths without cover
edge so or with minimal coverage so you
have six reads basically supporting the
alignment at this small region of the
genome well recovered is kind of an
example of a read depth recovered with
that read f you have it's the breadth of
the nucleotides that are covered so you
have all those you have multi have the
whole sequence the whole region area
being covered but you only have one or
two reach the kind of stuff will support
it so once you have once you have lined
to the genome you depending on the type
of sequencing you're doing you end up
doing this computational analysis and
that gives you this list of results with
some level of significance or confidence
level at the minimal and minimum and
there's multiple computational methods
that that for every type of sequencing
RNA seek DNA seek and all the mutant
algorithm statistical methods and that
has resulted in severe discrepancy in in
your results so just for me so you'll
have discrepancies and different results
based on your computational methods open
method alone so why do these analysis
differ it's because like I said
algorithms differ in like in the
assumptions of those algorithms are for
statistical models whether they assume
the normal distribution or things like
that correction methods and arbitrary
thresholds for statistical models as
well as parameters whether they
contribute if they even include a
background or how they include that
background or be sign or control
moreover the there's quality metrics at
each one of these steps so if the reads
from your alignment are are you have
fast you see you know they tell you the
quality of your airline you're the reads
from your sequencer and there's a whole
suite of tools that tell you the your
percent aligned or you
neatly mapped but there's really nothing
to tell you the tell you the quality
there's no exploratory data analysis for
the results and really you're kind of
guessing at the robustness of your
computational analysis and this is what
so my project so my framework will
attempt to obsess but will my framework
is basically to do exploratory analysis
fine metrics and visualizations they'll
test the robustness of this of the
computational methods from the results
and I'll do this in an interactive
context so using visualizations metrics
that are that whole that you can
interact with and like and and and like
really get your hands around the data
and it I'll do this obviously well and
you seem and like I said I'll do this
with using the interactive dynamics
being able to view and visualize
manipulate your data diagnosed your
results as well as the idea of
processing and provenance as well so my
second aim is to implement this
framework for two use cases copy number
variation and chip seek and these are
written at this point I won't focus
mostly on developing these use case if
achmet ryx and visualizations and really
to assess it and because all these all
these types of secrets are quite are
looking for different kinds of things
and so that they're lit so you need to
really develop use key specific ones as
well and I can kind of like integrate
them with the general metrics as well
and i'll use the interactive framework
shiny and are for this which is a web
app framework now i think really the
even the m1 i'll be developing these
general metrics and uh and i think
they're better understood if I explain
them in terms
of these cases and I think they'll
they'll make them they will mate said
they'll the better understood if I
explain them in the in terms of my two
use cases which are copy number
variation in ship Zeke so i'll start by
being beat start by giving you a little
background on these two as well and then
i'll go into some general metrics as
well as use key specifics for both of
them as well that have come explored so
copy number variation looks at tries to
find large variations in the genome
associated with disease and negative
phenotypes and chip seek identifies
these genetic locations associated with
protein and differentiation at these
genetic locations all ultimately causes
differentiation in the protein processes
as an aqua quartz differentiation
genetic regular regulation and
structural changes which ultimately
cause diseases so copy number variation
is are these large greater than a
thousand nucleotide regions that are
that are very and very very eight and
not long in the genome so on the the
first example i have is where your
reference reference or matches a sample
and it's kind of this is what this is
what normal normal looks like and then a
copy number loss is shown by this
deletion where you have your reference
gene and then your sample is missing
that chunk of gene of g of genome a copy
number gain or duplication or insertion
can Kimmy either be a duplication or
insertion where the gene is either
inserted or duplicated on the sample or
its insert into and another part of the
genome all together so there's various
message to detect these copy number
detectors what I have here is a read
depth method and so you're looking at
these 50 base pair
300 base pair of reeds and your look
trying to find and you're trying to find
these large ones right and so you're
looking at read this and you can see
that this is a copy number loss so
there's a significant less read depth in
this region as well different copy
number detectors also quantitate copy
number 22 copy numbers differently as
well so they use different computational
methods as well as algorithms and
different assumptions as well as the
statistical model for these detectors
very very significantly as well so
whether so significant stress holes
assumption distribution assumptions so
this variation has led to some severe
discrepancies and copy number detectors
this figure shows for copy number
detectors with 33 exome samples and you
can see that they're in concordance like
the match it match up here means that
means a fifty percent of overlap of
these copy number deter copy number
variants needed to be overlap for
concordance and you can see there's a
significant amount of discordant as well
as and you don't really know what's
important I mean yeah you could take
this significant 7 the khala overlap of
773 but like tikki said that's not
likely to show tell you the
unanticipated parts of your results so
what I have here is the my mock-up of
what I built in shiny and this is a
death of coverage is that working that's
the coverage up here and the blue region
this blue bar here is connected to this
range right here sorry I think I'm
running out of batteries so as you focus
on the depth eric the this region right
here
the Venn diagram is kind of really well
be reactive and so the number of copying
so it's basically showing the number of
copy number variants at that location at
that blue bar location at that blue bar
location so does that make sense like so
let me show you in an example so as I
focused in on this reef depths region
that has no Rita you can see by the box
plot at the above there's no read that
set in this region so the number of copy
number variants called by this method as
this method not only decrease
significantly from the Lark from the
prior one the number of the percent the
overlaps of the copy number is called
also the decreased showing that like
this low signal region not only had less
calls it also produce less reproducible
signal as well and in this in this part
in this slide I focused on the region
with higher read up and higher coverage
and you get more overlap in the number
of copy number detective copy number
variants that you call as well so you
get more reproducible signal ultimately
too so chromatin immunoprecipitation is
more targeted form of sequencing in this
a little brief protocol that I have here
you Frank you have the DNA that's bound
to the protein and then you fragment it
and then you use a minyan precipitation
to be which uses an antibody a specific
antibody excuse me to bind the pike a
specific proteins and so the antibody is
usually bound to some kind of medium
like a silica bean and you end up trying
to use that the specific antibody to
fill out the DNA and protein complexes
that you're interested in so you end up
so you purify this this complex and then
you add in the by slitting DNA and so
you can see how the only reads that you
shoot you
should get should be from this from the
parts of the only DNA reads that you
should get should be the ones that the
ones that interacted with that protein
so your lima pro profile ends up looking
like this so you get this your lemon
profile looks like a bunch of stacked
reads on top of each other and so here's
your reads and would your approach and
what you get are these peaks of signal
and so so a lots of these so these
algorithms are computational methods to
find these four chip seek are called P
colors and you can see how read depth
can be is a really important statistics
at this step now if you don't have
enough free theft you're not going to be
able to call these peaks because they'll
be that you won't they won't be
basically stack on top of each other
these out these computational methods
also have a problem of overfitting as
well so if your peak detectors or is too
sensitive not only will you call this an
obvious peak as my husband called it
Dubai vs detroit so like not only will
you see dubai this PK which is obviously
a peak but you'll see the five peaks or
however many in area B which only have
one or two reads really kind of
supporting them as well which is the
most more likely noise than anything
else so there's variation in these
computational methods as well as
experimental bit sources of variation
like antibody as well the end up whether
it's how specific the antibody is as
well as fragmentation as well as what
you're trying to find in the first place
so also transcription factors which is
the red Peaks above ctcf is a
transcription factor only like these two
to three hundred based binding regions
have these two to three hundred binding
regions so you can see them as like
really sharp peaks and in his wall
another spectrum histone modifiers have
have these wide binding region
which are like kilobases thousands of
bases wide so the variability in
chionship in these tipsy to tech peak
detectors has really caused variability
and results so on the left here you have
12 p collars as in the and this is just
an account number of peak colors at the
h one of these peak color is called and
43 transcription factors and you can see
that it's completely random that there's
no number called there's no pattern and
the number called or anything like that
anandam figure on the right you have a
single binding region for stat6 which is
also a transcription factor and the
binding motif is on the bottom here and
so this is kind of what supposed to with
your supposed to see and then above it
you have 11 chippy callers as well so
not only did so not only do you get this
variation in the number of Peaks called
the you get this complete complete
discrepancy in the binding region called
identified as well so one of the use key
specific metrics that I'm going to that
i plan on developing is this fraction of
reeds in peak and so in a perfect IP you
would isolate only that specific protein
right so it's like perfect IP and all
the sequencing reads from that chip seek
should be only from that peak from the
peaks itself and from signal so the
frick score is usually is tells you like
the success of your experiment it's over
the whole genome or over the whole
sample so you so you would expect it to
be kind of high like for example if you
want if you look in this window you and
here's your peaks and your signal was
this peak and maybe this blue tango peak
here your fraction of reeds in this
window is pretty high so it's a good
diagnostic on the quality of whether
you're at in your participation work
as well as like weather and and but so
but a low fripp skoura obvious what
could be failure of IP or like maybe you
didn't or because your particular was
completely horrible or something like
that so it's really a symmetric about
the success of your experiment so cyst
this is one of the general metrics that
I've developed and this irreducibly
discovery rate really addresses the one
of the main problems and comparing
computational methods and like and and
algorithms and and it's really because
they all use different statistical
threshold so a p-value q give a your
local threshold and then it kind of
incomparable and lee it all suggested a
solution to this using this irreducible
discovery discovery rate and this
attempts to find the threshold where
signal from up these is biological
replicates and intensifying the signal
where replicates stop no longer agree
with each other so it's assuming that
like reproducible signal is a true
signal and all noise is not reproducible
right so in this plot here you have rank
proportion its proportion that's why
it's a decimal and an error per
disability score and basically perfect
cordance is represented with a straight
line with a slope of 1 no no concordance
or correspondence between the replicates
is represented with an x squared curve
so you will be trying to find this
transition from where the straight line
turns into a curve and then or where
these biological kids go from
reproducible to not reproducible and
this alternative method of finding the
significance threshold for samples is
more robust in like an arbitrary I'd
alpha 0 point 05 or ninety five percent
and it's because it's derived
empirically from your samples itself
so this is how the speaker shows how I'm
going to use IDR and term to explore the
robustness of these algorithms and
computational methods so biological
replicates will be analyzed in parallel
separately but in parallel and then the
and then multiple algorithms can be
combined and then the idea and then the
number of hits basically found by each
out each one of these algorithms can be
compared as well so if you if like one
algorithm has produces like ten heads
while another algorithm produces 10,000
that and both had an ID at their eye dr
so you can really get a sense of the
sensitivity of that algorithm of both
algorithms at that point as well as
other general exploratory metrics using
this eye dr method the that threshold
versus arbitrary threshold by the
algorithm and this interactive component
it provides a way of kind of optimizing
your ID are so you not only get like you
can choose you can tweak your ID are
basically so you can like let's say you
have a known positive and that and for
one of the algorithms it would it be it
was it was beyond that threshold IDR and
you want it to get set to so it's
included so you can try to tweak your
algorithm or your eye dr for and set it
lower for that algorithm and so you're
known positive is including all that
algorithm it's kind of waited like it's
kind of a way to tweak your sensitivity
and so you can get so you can get a fair
comparison of all these algorithms and
and methods
so the impact from this interactive
framework it will be all ultimate to
increase accessibility in data in the
data as well as a methods that we use to
analyze the data and we'll use metrics
and visualizations to like expose this
data for analysis and ultimately I'm
hoping it will increase reproducibility
as well as well as credibility by like
by like directly associate at you use
filter these this all your data or
transform your data to do it and being
able to source it and reproduce it the
framework will also provide a way of
comparing computational methods and
algorithms as well you can really see
how you can assess the strengths and
weaknesses of all these algorithms and
cut and that's it go so next steps would
be the possibility of you integrating
English gals galaxy ultimately I could
probably think of using outputs like get
K stuff the coverage or things like that
that are known and formatting it so you
can just directly input into our shiny
and get the visualization I think that
would be the easiest method and then as
well as user testing which is essential
for the usability of this and
collaborative models are important
because there you can that you can see
how the exploratory explore Toria
metrics will be essential for large
larger and larger datasets where you
have collaborative studies and so you
will sometimes you will have multiple
people trying to use the same visual
interactive visualization so I think
your best method to or that integration
of multiple users will be it's pretty
important as well as examination another
sequencing workflows which is and this
problem of irreducibility is more than a
CMV or chip seek problem and we on the
figure on the left shows
RNA seek differential expression methods
and it shows five differential
expression methods and four and you can
see what a what I think was most
disconcerting about this diagram is a
big fat zero in the center and but its
RNA splicing which is like a difficult
problem to detect in the first place
there are some concerns here as well as
mutation callers for DNA seek these are
for me this paper assessed for mutation
colors and you can see that nut not
sorry it's a difficult figure to see but
the number there's the discrepancy in
the number of Peaks number of mutations
called as well as a proportion called as
well and that's it and I'd like to think
my committee Shannon watching in DC and
Mike my cloth luchia and Kamal and
Heinrich love and cargo and lab and
demise and friends and family
interesting topic so I'm wondering about
all the parameters for each of these
methods that you're using so would you
use your metric to also compare
different parameter settings for say
different differential expression or oh
well I don't I think that's more of an
extension for RNA seek and as well as
pigmentation as mutation colors they're
definitely applicable so that we can
kind of see how death and coverage or
kind of universal and that's part of
what I'm area first dance is to develop
these general Ames so you can really so
you can so potentially could probably
apply it to these other methods as well
Sen answer your question no but I mean
even for the the methods that you took
like copy numbers somebody talked about
like every one of those methods every
one of those algorithms is going to have
you know 500 different parameters that
you could change and then you could do a
bunch of different ways of aligning it
easy to grow yeah four parameters on
oh so there's just a huge noise a copy
yeah a lot of variation absolutely well
well what I wanted to do is just come to
the baseline so like for example like
there's only so much I can tweak about
every single like for chip seek alone I
think the last count that went in like
twenty twelve was at 35 p callers
different kinds of peak callers which is
huge you can't do every single parameter
for every one of those but you can kind
of get them on the seed basis so you can
see the benefits in pros and cons of
each like the eye dr a lot of these
methods use their you know their own
statistical program or FDR or any
statistical method to filter if you take
that statistical aspect out and then
filter by IDR you can just test the
algorithm and let use and just kind of
get them on the baseline and see which
one perform better there just by taking
the full spectrum of signal instead of
the filtered and the queued and
corrected and so you can tweak what you
can find you can get them on the same
baseline i guess and like and really get
the component the core components that
in companies and try to compare them
instead of trying to find all the
parameters obviously because there's all
the defaults right now like a million
and one defaults that are hidden in
there so to change with different
versions exactly yes yes and so you can
only do so much but i think there's you
know at the core there I think the
computation like the computation you can
really assess robustness there and kind
of go from there as well do you have a
gold standard by which you're assessing
the quality of the agreement and the
quality of the disagreement um look for
like copy number and stuff like that
everyone kind of uses a different method
like I know for copy number there was
fifty percent overlap or fifty percent
overlap in terms of X or act like
concordant exons and required fifty
percent overlap of that
Exxon and then they just count the
number of Concordat Exelon's that makes
sense yeah so there's a lot of ways
there's a lot of ways to measure
concordance and I think just when you're
comparing them this consistency is all
you can really hope for and like and as
well as well as it like consistency in
comparison so you know if you know from
your known data set along those lines
are there any data sets for which you
know people have actually found
something and verified that they found
something for us I'm wondering if
there's pre existing data that you can
use where someone has experimentally
verified well you can simulate the data
as well but I'm you cannot you can
simulate data as well as with chips
equal you have like no one would tease
you know where where there's where
people have cataloged all these binding
regions and you can use those as a basis
for like how the accuracy of whatever
your peak color defined as well so
there's measures of accuracy that you
can do without actually having to
simulate data or things like that
actually that was the exact question
that I was going to ask so I'll extend
it and I know this may go beyond the
scope of your work but you know there's
a lot of areas of informatics where
where we you know a lot of testing of
algorithms is based on some sort of gold
standard and we try to optimize the
algorithm or use learning algorithms or
whatever to achieve that optimization so
here I assume at some point you will
yeah something that might be the right
the right answer haha and then how will
that be used by the the bench scientist
to you know advance this work I mean I
assume you're looking for things that a
bit scientists can then study further
how would someone use the result if you
could find the right answer oh oh that's
it that's interesting bowl that is the
best there's obviously best practices in
the genomics world and like and and but
obviously you can
you can make the users best practice I
know broad has a whole system and like
broad gat k pipelines are like a gold
standard a lot a lot of the time and it
just like you can you can use these
measures of accuracy but ultimately what
I a plan what I see from this framework
is I mean it's a way to comply assess
how accurate your method was you know
right like I yeah you can have this gold
standard but ultimately for different
kinds of whatever you're looking for it
might not work that but well for example
using like this transcription factors
versus histone modifiers those peak
regions if you use the you can see how
algorithms you optimize for
transcription factors or these tiny
little Pete's wouldn't perform so well
unlike these large Peaks so I think it
ultimately there is no they're like a
gold standard for the one use case isn't
necessarily the gold standard for all
use cases and you need you need a method
to basically assess how to assess that
though so you don't really know until
you realize oh why is my dear like why
do I have you know I should only have a
thousand hits but now i have two hundred
thousand or 500,000 i know and like
things like that that that kind of flag
your data and that really gets into the
exposure and you can't really like know
what what it did until you actually run
it and see what that it's inaccurate
things like that answer your question
right right okay yes
you